good morning I'm Norah O'Donnell and as
we continue our earth matter series on
this Earth Day I'm pleased to welcome
former Secretary of State John Kerry to
our CBS this morning Toyota Green Room
welcome a Secretary of State we should
point out under President Obama Kerry
was instrumental in the 2016 signing in
the International Paris climate
agreement last year the Trump
administration announced its intent to
withdraw from the agreement secretary
good morning good morning why have you
made fighting climate change one of your
great missions well I've been involved
in public life now
for what 45 or 50 years of all the
issues we've ever been involved in and
I've been involved with nuclear weapons
with cyber with terrorism this is the
single most challenging security issue
for everybody on the planet it's life
and death and people need to tune into
that more it's very hard for people to
grapple with it because they think oh my
god it's too big I can't do anything
about it but the point is everybody can
and must and most importantly this is
the most important it's not a choice
between doing something for the
environment and having a job or living
comfortably the future will be defined
by clean energy alternative energy
renewable energy that's a certainty
electric cars a certainty and the issue
is how quickly are we going to do this
will we do it in time to minimize the
great damage that is being done though
to those who say well I don't see
climate change we've had the last four
warmest years on earth forever Alaska
the warmest March its ever had by a lot
I mean we can go on and on there's a
report today in The Associated Press
that
Hawaii's Waikiki Beach where my parents
honeymoon
could soon be underwater because of
rising sea levels yeah Miami yeah I mean
you can run around the world and
identify the cities that will absolutely
find major floods they're having sunny
day floods today nowadays in Boston we
have a seawall and on a sunny day at a
high tide you can see water coming up
over the flood
most people are predicting that with the
melting that's currently taking place in
the Arctic and Antarctic
so we're gonna have about three feet sea
level rise in the course of this century
that's a century but we're now learning
that the ocean is warming 40% faster
than it was 10 years ago we're learning
that the Greenland ice sheet is melting
four times faster than it was 10 years
ago so everything has accelerated I mean
the storms are more intense the fires
and more intense because there's a cycle
of rain and and growing brush and then
more tinderbox and then it ignites so
the channel it's exciting or is if we
move rapidly now to embrace alternative
technologies and make choices we can
beat this it can actually become the
biggest marketplace the world has ever
seen create millions of jobs huge
amounts of money will be made by the
people who are technologies absolutely
explain what the Paris agreement would
collectively do in terms of all of the
nations that signed on well the Paris
agreement we worked in after years of
failure we went to Paris and we
negotiated with the Chinese I went to
try now we negotiated with the Chinese
we finally got the Chinese to be
cooperative not opposed to us that
created an entirely new dynamic so
President Obama and President Xi were
able to stand up in Beijing and announce
to the world two years Anna Paris this
is what we're going to do we're going to
reduce our emissions then Europe
followed and then 196 countries came to
Paris and said we're all going to reduce
our emissions but it was a voluntary
agreement
nothing mandatory so the real thing we
believed we were doing in Paris was not
guaranteeing that we're going to hold
the earth's temperature to two degrees
centigrade what we guaranteed was the
marketplace is going to get excited
people going to invest and guess what
the next year for the first time in
history more money three hundred and
fifty billion dollars was invested in
alternative and renewable energy rather
than fossil fuel so Solar is now cheaper
than coal it's about 80
percent reduction in the cost of solar
wind is about 69 percent cheaper than it
was 10 years ago
everything's happening faster it's what
technology does so if we will embrace
this and make wise decisions we can get
to have the curb if we don't embrace it
there will be literally trillions of
dollars of damage and we will lose lives
many lives people are already dying
because of climate change
it will happen there'll be refugees food
shortage interruption there'll be water
interruption that's going to become a
and if you think migration there's a
challenge today you already see people
leaving Guatemala and Honduras because
of climate change they can't grow things
where they used to so I think it's
without alarming anybody and I'm not
alarmist because I see so many good
things that we can do that will help
people why the pushback why from
president it's ideological and and
frankly it's short-sighted and it's
stupid and it's dangerous president
Trump's decision to pull out of Paris
will cost lives lives of Americans it
will cost billions of dollars and I'll
give an example last year we we spent or
two years ago now we spent two hundred
and sixty five billion dollars cleaning
up after three storms Harvey in Texas
drop more water in five days then goes
over Niagara Falls an entire year it's
an unprecedented what they called it
once and fifty thousand year flood but
it's now happening more frequently and
and and Maria the other storm devastated
Puerto Rico and Irma was the first
Hummer cane to have sustained winds over
a hundred and eighty five miles an hour
for 24 hours this is affecting their
every chance every taxpayer in terms of
bailing out and Kleenex payers are
already paying the money and there are
countless economic analyses that show it
is cheaper to make the investments and
do the things we need to do now to
prevent the damage than it is to wait
for the damage I mean the global GDP is
about two hundred and eighty trillion
dollars today scientists and
William Nordhaus at Yale just won the
Nobel Prize for economics for this
analysis shows that if we don't do
things at the rate that we're not doing
them today in this compounds the cost to
the world will be twice the global
global GDP today
so everything compels us to move in this
direction except we have a president who
doesn't read doesn't understand the
science and has ideologically decided to
side with the deniers who literally
don't know what they're talking about
what's the single greatest thing an
individual can do to help fight climate
change
vote vote and vote I mean the simple
reality is that turnout when President
Trump was elected was fifty four point
two percent when I ran for president
against bush no for the turnout was
about sixty point three percent when
Obama won in oh eight it was about sixty
three percent so you see the difference
you you you if you don't vote you get
what you don't vote for and and the
point is that in the United States of
America of all places in the world the
greatest democracy we're the ones who
who who encourage and and and market
democracy to other countries and and I
think it's great we do but we're not
living our own democracy particularly
effectively right now what industries
are the biggest contributors to climate
change the biggest contributors to
climate change are transportation and
the production of electricity we have to
move to electric cars to clean cars move
away from combustion and we have to get
away from fossil fuel the production of
electricity and we can do that but even
the Democratic Party and those running
for president not even a majority of
them support taxes a carbon tax
yes well many people do there are
different forms of a carbon tax but it's
bipartisan Secretary of State Jim Baker
and secretary former Secretary of State
George Shultz that put out a plan which
in principle I support the framework of
the plan they're details in it we need
to try to work out but it it prices
carbon and if you price carbon then
people will begin to make different
choices based on the cost of products
contain carbon or come from carbon other
countries do more of that or I mean we
need to be undertaking greater effort in
Paris we created something called
mission innovation China signed up to it
India signed up to it and 23 other
countries and the European Union we're
pushing technology in this effort
because one of the things we're gonna
actually have to do is something called
negative emissions if we're really gonna
get ahead of this we have to be able to
take carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere so the whole concept of how
do you do that and what do you do with
that there's an enormous part of the
research we need to be doing and what do
you do to do that well there are ways
that you can capture carbon we do
capture carbon today my plan there are
companies that are currently using
captioned carbon to put back into the
earth and it pushes oil out so it's
called an enhanced oil production
process so it actually helps you
retrieve oil that you couldn't retrieve
otherwise there are other
I mean people put into concrete and it
can be stored in a building in the
context of car there are different ways
people are exploring we haven't found
the magic key but the key is to be
working out of it there's one thing I
know when the United States puts its
mind to going to the moon or to trying
to reduce AIDS in Africa and we're on
the brink of the first generation of
children being born aids-free that's us
yeah we can do these things it's in our
DNA and we got to go do which became a
bipartisan effort by the way you know
was bipartisan yes it was it was
bipartisan from the beginning actually
bill first and I he was then Senate
Majority Leader passed the first stage
legislation which then became and we did
with Jesse Helms and support and it
became PEPFAR under President Bush
that's a great success you have led by
congressman Alexandra occasion Cortes
the Green Deal mm-hmm which the goal is
to have 100% clean energy by 2030 is
that realistic and is it realistic let
me just say first of all because
everybody has been attacking her and I
think
very unfairly she's had the courage to
stand up and put forward an aspiration
and it's a generalized statement of an
aspiration not a specific piece of
legislation but actually trying to
achieve a completely carbon free
alternative renewable society but 2010
is not possible we just can't do that
yet what we're aiming for there's a
former secretary Ernie Moniz Secretary
of Energy he and I are working on
something which we hope to be able to
announce in a few weeks and some major
proposal and a major initiative that we
think can really help change the
politics right now but what we're
talking about include well what we're
talking about more importantly is
setting a goal by 23rd 2015
it was just 30 years approximately to
move to a low-carbon no net carbon
society and I say net no net carbon
because there will be offsets you're
gonna be using gas as a bridge fuel for
a virtuous grid for instance when you
don't have wind you don't have Sun you
don't have hydro you're gonna need
something to keep the DB cameras working
and and and so forth and then our
industry and and that's doable plus we
are now becoming far far more advanced
in battery storage if we can break the
secret of really big battery storage and
small and less expensive form then solar
becomes a massive massive alternative
for everybody but you have to be able to
do something for those times when you
just don't have the Sun finally
secretary Kerry I think there were now
up to 20 Democrats running for president
yeah and the most ever the most ever
running for president Joe Biden will
make 21 if he enters on them Joe is
qualified and obviously should be
running III I don't want to get into a
commentary on everybody but I I don't
think this is helpful for the Democratic
Party I mean it's not particularly
helpful for the country I think it's
helpful to have a healthy primary but as
many candidates as we have today I think
is
is complicated for voters and
complicated for the raising of money and
you should get roots the Democratic
Party or the house will do I don't think
it has yet but it certainly has
potential to if people start going after
each other and if there's a polarization
within the party that that it becomes a
wound too hard to heal we have to be
careful of that I'm hoping that won't
happen
I pray it won't happen but we heard the
former President Barack Obama he's
served with say that it was almost close
to becoming I think what was the word he
used a circular firing squad
Democrats historically have been pretty
good at avoiding shooting at each other
I hope that won't happen I think most
most of the candidates that I've taken
note about that's for focused on
important issues I think there are a lot
of good ideas being put on the table I
think they're doing a good job of
promoting the thinking but clearly I
mean what does it mean if you wind up
with a nominee who basically was
narrowed down by you know team in the
teams of presenting support I don't
think it builds the momentum and effort
to get well let's see what happens there
are people still getting in I'm looking
forward to Joe's announcement we'll see
where we are well secretary Kerry nice
to have you here celebrated the first
Earth Day I was they are working in the
first Earth Day and I was chairman of
New England Earth Day in 1990 and and
whatever Ernie and I are doing now will
coordinate very closely with Earth Day
and all the people involved in that and
every other environmental group out
there because we need everybody on deck
it has to become a voting issue how do
you make it a voting issue you've got to
connect people to how their lives are
affected by what's happening how their
pocketbook is affected but also show
them this does not mean a choice between
their job or their comfort level or
their quality of life all of that can
get better more jobs better pay better
lifestyle longer life less cancer less
pollution in the air I mean they're all
the side benefits that just don't get
talked about and we're gonna see to it
that they are talking about always great
to see you happy never do happy Earth
Day thank you thank you my pleasure to
do it